make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking up with the
conclusion or really ending with the
conclusion
of silver surfer block which is a story
you guys really
really seem to enjoy i'll be honest i
had no idea you guys were going to like
this story so much when i first started
it i was like we're just going to do
this just because of everything going on
with noel might as well throw it in
there right so we understand what's
going on with the silver surfer but i'm
glad you guys dig it i'm glad you guys
really enjoy it uh so having said that
so in the last video we basically picked
up with the idea that silver surfer
basically ran into ego the living planet
who was kind of this disembodied voice
that was guiding the silver surfer away
from knoll under the idea that
surfer simply just didn't have the power
to defeat noel and that's still true
right he just doesn't have
that ability to pull it off the crazy
thing about it though is that ego
existing at this point in time still
shows us that null has not necessarily
conquered the entirety of the universe
right and we know that even for the most
part his crusade didn't necessarily
succeed in that way that he was
ultimately stopped by the celestials and
then banished to a different dimension
right all that was covered
when we first started covering like noel
the symbiote god his origin all that
kind of good stuff
the important thing here is that with
silver surfer conversing
with with ego what we end up finding out
here is that ego has a kind of infection
inside of him right it's kind of a
there's this thing that seemed to crash
into him and has more or less been
causing him immense agony
ever since it first arrived and so
surfer ends up traveling
inside the body of ego which ego doesn't
initially tell them is a good idea right
it's kind of you probably shouldn't do
this man because i am a living planet
like i do have an immune system
and in your weakened state that immune
system may very well kill you right but
the response to the server is
it doesn't matter right in this instance
like i need your help in this uh and if
this is causing you immense pain i will
cure it i will get rid of it and then
you and i will work together right so
entering down inside the body of ego
what he ends up finding here
is galactus he ends up fighting galactus
and that's kind of a crazy thing right
because
this is new stuff this is stuff that
that's really kind of being made up on
the spot
with regards to galactus that whenever
it is that you look at marvel comics
when it comes to the origin of galactus
he was originally gallon in the universe
that came before the the current
universe as it exists
and that you ended up seeing uh him just
kind of being born into this almost
energy-like state he basically created a
cocoon around himself
and that in turn he emerged from it and
the first planet he consumed was
archeopia this is more or less new
information being thrown in but at the
same time
it's kind of not right and that's what
makes things a little wonky that
traditional origin of galactus
comes from what we call the sixth
universe right and he was born into the
seventh universe which is
this the the version of the universe
that we saw that led up to secret wars
in 2015
right this is could be looked at as a
new universe but it's one of these
things where marvel kind of confirmed it
possibly is but it's possibly not
because it's got a new name but it's
still the same numerical designation so
by all standards of measurement this
is the the same universe that we've
always been in right so it's basically
marvel changing the origin
of or at least a portion of the origin
of galactus in the sense that when he
first emerged inside this universe that
he crashed into ego the living planet
and it's kind of nuts to know that like
null and ego and and galactus were all
sort of occupying the same sector of the
universe
around the same time but ultimately
silver surfer travels directly inside
this you know kind of protective sphere
of galactus with the intention
of essentially killing him right like
once he once he emerges like once he
leaves he kind of puts this great big
huge chain around it then once he leaves
he intends to pull it and to get rid of
it because the because ego asks him like
what are you going to do with this he's
like i'm going to kill him i'm going to
take him into a star and drop him off
right a white dwarf star
and like drop him off in there and his
energy's just going to disperse but as
he gets there with the intention of
killing galactus who watching the
watcher pops up and who watches the
watcher
basically stops him and says you can't
do this and it's one of these things
where he kind of points to this idea
you're from billions of years in the
future you're back here in the past
but understand it's not going to change
you it's not as though killing galactus
is going to undo everything that's
happened and they're going to go you
know the whole universe is going to
reset itself and you're going to go back
to being on zen law and galactus will
have never come there and you'll never
have become the silver surfer and you'll
be able to live your life with shaola
ball
understand every action has a
consequence and there's no knowing what
the consequence of this action is going
to be you know and he kind of runs off
these these different alternate
realities right he's like there's one
universe where you die alone on zen law
there's another universe where you grow
old with your wife and children
there's one universe which we saw from
the thanos wins storyline where
basically he ends up dying against
thanos in the far-flung future
while he's wielding mjojnir right any
one of these is possible
and if he kills galactus in his infancy
any one of them can come to fruition so
there's not a guarantee here right and
that's the thing that'll watch you says
you're not guaranteeing a better future
here you could make things infinitely
worse
we saw that with the death of galactus
in the old the old stories of the
fantastic four with the rise of abraxas
right the galactus basically died and it
unleashed abraxas across the multiverse
and he killed every version of galactus
across the multiverse that he could
possibly find right he just literally
almost wiped out everything right so
abraxas was wildly powerful that's just
one of the many possibilities that exist
out there and so ultimately uwatu is
like if you're still hell bent on this
idea of killing galactus then at least
go talk to a person who's
survived the death of a universe only to
be born in the next one and has in
effect made the same choice you have and
so silver surfer
enters into this cube of galactus into
this kind of stasis
body more or less and then comes across
gallon right encounters gallon and has a
conversation with him
and when galan asks like who are you and
why are you here the response of the
surfer is i mean to kill you
and and when when galactus asks why he
says it's because of all the
the the horrors that you're going to
commit later on as you progress you're
going to emerge
from this cube basically this kind of
stasis cell when you're gathering your
energies and then you're officially
going to enter the universe as galactus
and you're just going to consume worlds
and you're going to kill
countless beings right trillions and
trillions and trillions of beings for
billions of years across the cosmos
because you have to feed because you
kind of
maintain this sort of balance in the
universe or at least you claim you do
right silver surfer alma kind of almost
kind of calls them into question
and so when when silver surfer says my
job here what i want to do is basically
eliminate you
so that all these horrors can basically
come to an end then the response of
galactus is
then aren't you the same as me in that
case right if my existence here in this
universe
serves the purpose of maintaining a kind
of balance between the light and the
dark that i consume worlds to sustain my
essence in order to ensure that like
whatever forces may come across this
universe that i as a cosmic being
am constantly alive right that's kind of
the role that i that i play and you
intend to kill me based on some kind of
cosmic balance that you've created for
yourself then what's the difference
between the two of us
and and really like silver surfer
doesn't really have an answer for that
and so the responsive gallon is do as
you feel you should right but if there's
one thing that i've learned over the
course of my existence it's this you
cannot defeat the dark with darkness it
doesn't work that way right you cannot
become as bad as the people you're
fighting in order to win you have to
kind of maintain a higher ground now
i don't necessarily agree with that you
know i don't really agree with that
philosophy uh but there is truth to the
statement of uwati the watcher
if silver surfer were to kill gallon in
his current form which he's capable of
doing that in turn he could lead to a
worse future the universe could be far
worse off without galactus than it is
with galactus and so because of that
being the case
that basically leads to the surfers
saying okay fine then we're not gonna do
that right we're not gonna play that
game he ends up basically taking the
the cube of galactus and just flying it
across the cosmos where it'll eventually
arrive at the planet of archeopia where
galactus will emerge for the first time
and then basically consume that world
the way he's supposed to right kind of
ensuring the timeline continues away
that is supposed to continue on from
there he ends up traveling directly back
to ego and he asks ego for a favor he's
like i need i need you to give me
a portion of your power right give me a
portion of your ability because i'm
going to need it for the thing that's
coming and he takes this sole bit of
power immerses it within himself
and then in turn travels to find nol or
at least nol finds him right noel ends
up locating him
directly on you know directly where ego
is at and so the two of them kind of set
a trap to a degree now one thing to
understand
is that because of the fact that he's
been ripped through this black hole
because he's been put in the you know
thrown into the past here
along with his encounter with noel the
silver surfer is in effect dying right
his body is basically falling apart on
the atomic level it's a slow process but
a process that's happening nonetheless
and so the last great deed the silver
surfer wants to commit here
is basically ending or at least trying
to end the crusade of knoll the symbiote
god and so where nol comes flying in at
silver surfer silver surfer takes this
portion of this energy and plants it in
himself and then basically starts going
and fighting towards uh fighting
fighting with null right now in this
moment when null is flying towards
surfer the move is put in by ego to
basically blast
null with this huge amount of energy or
all this magma as hard as you can which
null basically dodges out of the way
right so that that attack doesn't
necessarily work
from there it's almost this kind of cat
and mouse game between the silver surfer
and null where nulls chasing the surfer
the surfers bobbing and weaving
and then taking these little pot shots
at null it's one of these things where
it's obvious the silver surfer cannot
necessarily beat him but as he keeps
going through and encountering null and
as he keeps using his power cosmic which
is being reduced over and over again
because of these encounters
the the all black of null keeps
consuming him more and more the silver
surfer his body keeps falling apart
more and more and more and more and
that's why you see his body basically
shifting from being silver to becoming
more of like a black almost intangible
color
all the while maintaining this energy
inside his body and so ultimately he
ends up summoning his board
and then crafting an enormous sword and
he and null finally battle one another
in kind of a ritualistic combat type
thing but null gets the upper hand
because again silver server is just not
on the same power as null and so as the
two of them continue fighting
finally null ends up pinning him down
right ends up pinning him down and then
basically
trying to force a symbiote directly onto
him and ultimately he keeps saying like
your power belongs to me right like all
this this light that you have
all this ability you have it's going to
be mine you are going to be my knight
because it's one of the things that we
established in the last video the silver
surfer is immensely powerful and if you
can become a source of power for
null then there's almost no telling what
the two of them can pull off together
more than enough to kill galactus and
certainly more than enough to conquer
the universe but the silver surfer has
one last ace up his sleeve
using what little power cosmicky has
remaining he in turn says
fine then if what you want is all this
energy all this light that i have
then take it and he uses it to spawn a
miniature sun
and basically grows it in the face of
null and as we know light energy things
like that
are kind of like a weakness for normal
that's one of the reasons why he likes
having this universe or this section of
the
universe
filled with darkness because he wants to
kind of fill the entire universe with
darkness there's no light no
none of that stuff and so using this
basically sends null
flying across the cosmos right it also
changes his appearance and makes him
look the way that he does right now in
the current day but it sends them flying
across the cosmos the problem with this
for the silver surfer is that it's not
enough to kill nol
right it's just enough to kind of push
him at bay but what he ends up doing is
basically using his power
along with the power that he received
from from uh from ego
to craft these kind of life seats right
these small little galactic
seeds as they're called and then he
plants some of them or really plants
most of them on this
this small little world which he names
zen law and then from there
takes off right like basically his
energy just kind of dissipates his his
physical form completely eradicates and
he kind of just dissipates and becomes
one with
all this you know the universe itself in
effect and so what he ends up doing is
by virtue of this
one zen law comes into existence so he
basically creates the world he hails
from
right so kind of a self-fulfilling
circular prophecy but his actions also
lead to the recreation of the worlds or
at least the formations of the worlds
that galactus had previously consumed
somewhere along the line right so while
he is in effect
creating the world that galactus would
later consume in essence he sees himself
as committing a good deed right that
while he's not really saving the lives
of the people who were destroyed by
galactus at the very least he's giving
birth to them right so it's almost kind
of like in some way he's
bringing them back to life where they
had previously died i don't know if that
really makes any sense it's really more
just kind of a personal
philosophical and almost moral answer
for the struggle that silver surfer's
been going through
over the course of all of his existence
but in essence his physical form as we
know it no longer exists his mental
essence right the the energy that makes
him who he is has dispersed across the
across the galaxy in the universe and
kind of given birth to everything and so
following that what he ends up doing is
he basically re-emerges
uh from the black hole but as a
intangible all-black being
now this happens at the same time that
storm breaker basically emerges from the
black hole which is how like beta ray
bill and all those guys survive
that's why you didn't see silver surfer
emerge with all of them when he was
sucking the black hole alongside
everybody else because this is the story
he was experiencing but at this moment
right now
in marvel comics and even now going into
like the king in black with the
appearance of the silver server this is
why he looks the way he does he's
completely covered in black along with a
surfboard and he's intangible he doesn't
actually
have a physical form so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob port if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you